please welcome the phenomenal
megan repino
[Applause]
oh my gosh
okay i know you're engaged but you're so
hot i can't take it
oh don't tell sue i'm i'm just being
extremely respectful
i actually hate i i it's something i
hate when women flirt with married men
i'm like don't do that
um and you're engaged so i'm not
flirting with you but i just love you
and sue so much you're both so
attractive on the inside the outside
everything you do in the world oh my
goodness my goodness
hi hi i'm very excited to be here
i'm nervous i'm really excited to speak
with
you and um we're going to be speaking
with your mom
later as well um but let's start off
with you
and sue i was really loving your
engagement story
i love will you tell it please you were
on
vacation and
we were on vacation and in
it's like in typical megan fashion it
was
it was planned but there was no plan
if you know what i mean i have been
thinking about it for
a long time i think spending you know
every waking
hour and minute and day for months on
end um really solidified that we're not
going to kill each other
and that maybe we can actually make this
work in life so i had been thinking
about it and
you know we take this amazing vacation
with a bunch of our friends so
sue's turning 40. so we're a couple of
her friends so um
it was just a really special time around
people that we loved and
it's like the moment just presented
itself i didn't even
i still don't really have like a proper
uh ring for her but
you know i'm bucking up against the
status quo so i'm just going to get rid
of that i actually took a band off of my
my own hand and gave it to her um
yeah the the water it was a beautiful
time
she had kind of like come swimming over
i was sort of laying on that ledge
and it kind of hit me a little bit i was
like
is this the moment i'm kind of like
talking to myself like it's this moment
is this moment i was like i think this
is the moment and like
our friends were sort of paying
attention but not really
um so it was like oddly this really
intimate private moment and then as
people sort of started to figure out
there was maybe like nine of us
um our friend boots got an incredible
picture that's
that's the actual photo um thank you for
not selling it
um and making millions or something
boots but uh
it really was just a special sort of
spontaneous but
also um just a really sweet moment and
yet meant to be because you had a gold
band i know you're a big jewelry wearer
i am too
i put on this little floral brooch today
and lots of rings so
i i i could get married to six people
maybe today if i
wanted uh but i'm you know i just loved
that you were able i think that's so
meant to be that you were able to slip a
ring
a gold band off your own hand and
present it to her i just think that's
perfect now
how do you feel about not only do you
have the best book cover i've ever seen
but your story i mean there's so
much to who you are a fighter for equal
pay
a fighter for human rights and lgbtq
uh you know you care about voting
i didn't even know where to start with
all of the activism
that you take on and it's all here in
this book
i how do you feel about having this book
do you like the cover
you know what the the cover is a funny
story i actually push back on the cover
a lot i i think it's
very different than anything that i have
done
and it sort of looks different and it
just had this totally
different vibe and i actually went back
and forth a few times with the editor
and she was just like
i need to trump you on this like this is
this is amazing and you look beautiful
and it's a sort of different
peek into me than i think any other
photo that i've taken has so
i do love it now um i think it's really
resonated and
i think it looks really really good to
have an actual book
in the world is so bizarre i'm like
wait it's out there like people are
reading it's like i obviously knew that
the book was written and it was going to
be published but now that it's actually
out on the shelves and people are
reading it and then they're telling me
that they're reading it i'm like this is
so
like just amazing but a very surreal
feeling in a lot of ways
i have to say you know i are you a
control freak because i am
no no i'm not okay because i'm just kind
of like i just sort of let it out there
and i'm like
i'm glad you let your book editor take
the lead on this because i think it is
so striking and beautiful and it just
gets right down
to you without a lot of fuss around it
and i think
that's what's really interesting